yo you talked about working on your
relationship
which i think is dope because i don't
feel i'm married but i don't feel like
we hear enough artists talking about
we either like see the the the really
good parts
on instagram yeah or it's the quiet it's
the
polar opposite but i mean every
relationship is worse this [ __ ] real
man this [ __ ] and i been with my girl my
girl came along
like right like a year before i got
signed
mm-hmm and i'm fresh out of jail okay so
she got the right to say like
shout out it was double fold your family
right right right right and being in
this
being a relationship and coming up in
the industry especially me catering
to women you feel me i'm rhythmic
gangster i could go everywhere but my
song low key came out
towards women and to be dating the
family so it's just like damn man
but you gotta grow with it certain [ __ ]
you just gotta grow with you gotta stick
and move and hope that you understand
what you're signing up for
and and give them a whole idea and lay
everything out man that'd be the problem
with [ __ ] um
ain't nobody telling what you finished
signing up for i oh like i've always
tried to take the approach of like
because i've been through so many
[ __ ] relationships it's like you you
never want to stop dating your girl
you never want to stop dating her if
that makes sense
like they stop [ __ ] with that the
energy that you guys have when y'all
were dating
you know what i'm saying or when you
guys first started talking to each other
you kind of like you
like always want to make you got to be
kept cause i don't
i feel when you we talking we dating i
grew up like
i don't even mean like i don't even mean
like going on dates i just mean like
that energy like
i ain't even saying days i'm saying like
the moment we the moment
me and you say oh yeah we talking we
texting all that yeah
yeah everybody else cut off on your yeah
yeah
we in this hey man not a lot of people
share that sentiment for sure
i don't need to be playing like that
it's like yo if i'm taking the time out
to give you my energy
yeah this is special yeah